I can pinch first 445 pounds I could
flip the 270 pound tire I can do
handstand push-ups and I can climb I
look act look damn good doing it I was a
cruel and adaptive crossfitter and a
power lifter I was born with the
deformity and pretty much my legs looked
real messed up so I would never be able
to walk use them so they made a decision
to get them amputated
I've been an amputee double amputee
since I was 2 years old my relationship
with Fitness started out in high school
I just started lifting weights like
anybody else and I always always did it
for appearance at first if I'm just
going to be a torso I'm going to be one
damn looking good torso and then just
took over my life like I want to know
everything there is no about the anatomy
of the human body how to get stronger
what creates muscle growth like I was a
sponge I've been told I can't bench
press more than 400 pounds my ass I've
been told I wouldn't have a gym my own
my biggest motivation in life is people
tell me I can't do something for free
classes or free personal training to
adaptive athletes or people with
disabilities so I have a girl with
serial palsy I have a girl that has a
spinal cord injury and I have another
quadruple amputee that I'm personal
training right now CrossFit has done so
much for my life and I feel like I just
want to pass that on and show everybody
that it is possible you can work past
disabilities and wherever your goals are
especially fitness wise you can meet
them it's just going to be a little bit
different route than somebody else